[Music]
[Music]
serhat 570s down no movement we're gonna
need additional units have to kill him
like that they didn't have to shoot him
anytime and they get detected that came
in a cup sent me don't go outside or go
in and back than what helping to help
you out and kill one of my grandkids
because they come to the back door
my grandson was 23 years old
then I'd my great-great grandparents
don't have their daddy because their
neighbors why do you should have an arm
shoot him in the leg set a dog's send a
Taser why y'all didn't have his
cellphone
I just want justice for my grace and my
daughter my baby this is almost bad
justice I want justice for my baby
I want justice but step by part please
give us just one be careful sir be
careful
I never hate that moves what if you have
one of these this is dark and that's my
good weapon it does in your hand what
does that look like
hey there wait wait wait wait watch this
watch this
what does it look like in my hand
cellphone this is a magic trick now
watch this again watch this cellphone I
watched this was my brother
25 split ties